today's video is sponsored by floki
floki lets you learn how to play the
piano with the songs you love check them
out through the link in the description
below more on them in a bit imagine for
a second that aliens land tomorrow
bombed with futuristic weaponry they
take the world's leaders hostage turning
them into mere puppets they dismantle
humanity's great buildings destroy all
religion and mass execute anyone who
disobeys them if that sounds like
speculative fiction think again a
similar scenario already unfolded 500
years ago in 1519 conquistadors led by
Hernan Cortes landed on the edges of the
Aztec empire within a year that captured
the emperor Montezuma the second and
turned him into their unhappy puppet
shortly after the entire Empire
collapsed torn apart by the arrival of
the Europeans but while most of us know
the tale of Cortes how many of us know
the story of the Emperor he deposed how
many know what it must have felt like to
be Montezuma on the eve of his
civilizations collapse born into Aztec
royalty Montezuma was a man destined for
greatness as ruler he expanded his
empires reach until it dominated modern
Mexico yet when the aliens arrived this
great man could do nothing but watch as
his entire world crumbled today we're
journeying through an unrivaled
Mesoamerican superpower and uncovering
the tragic life of its last true emperor
[Music]
in the great library of history there
are leaders whose lives fill not just
shelves but entire rooms people like
George Washington whose every single
deed has been poured over innumerable
times on the other end of the scale you
have leaders whose lives are only a
single slim volume rulers whose
existence is such a mysteries that we
know almost nothing about them it's into
this latter category that Montezuma's
life falls born circa 1467 ad Montezuma
the second is one of those historical
figures haunted by misconceptions for
instance while this video is titled
Montezuma the second Aztec culture
didn't have regnal numbers to them it
just have been plain old Montezuma only
even that isn't quite right probably
wrens it his name should be this which
I'm not even gonna try and pronounce
purser it can be delightfully translated
as angry like a lord and this is an
emotion I'm sure we've all experienced
at one point or another we mentioned
this not to be pedantic dicks but to
demonstrate just how little most of us
know of one of America's most
significant pre-columbian figures but
even scholars don't know a great deal
more that's because a whole ton of
Montezuma's past has been lost to
history we know more or less when he was
born in the last years of the reign of
his namesake the first Montezuma we know
that his father was the future ruler
Axia Cattleman's that his uncle was also
an emperor in Waiting called out subtle
but if you're here to discover what kind
of relationship Montezuma had with his
mother or what he enjoyed doing as a kid
well we hate to disappoint you but we
can't say that for certain what we can
say though is that Montezuma came of age
during a time of transformation he was
just 2 or 3 years old when the Aztec
emperor or more properly the Atlanta
Hwanhee meaning speaker Montezuma the
1st died in the aftermath a council of
elders came together to decide who would
be next to rule the Empire
unlike European society Aztec culture
didn't automatically award the throne to
the dead guys eldest son instead
electing someone from a narrow list of
candidates this would turn out to be
very lucky for the young prince
despite his uncle a heads aatul being
older it was
Montezuma's father iooks a curtal who
was eventually chosen to become the
Tonto Ronnie from this point on
Montezuma's already pampered life likely
only got cushier as the son of the plant
Ronnie and the Aztecs considered that a
twonny to be literally divine Montezuma
would have sat at the top of a gigantic
pyramid made up of rigid social classes
it would have received the best
education learning the dark arts of
warfare in politics amid settings so
opulent they rivaled Versailles by the
time he came of age Montezuma would have
been as ready to rule as any king or
Emperor in history so maybe it's time we
discussed exactly what he was gonna rule
the Aztec empire was one of America's
greatest civilizations at its height it
ruled millions of people we've seen
estimates ranging from 6 million to over
11 million and around 500 cities most of
what we'd now call central Mexico fell
within its lands and its southern
extremity stretched the fringes of
Guatemala but this wasn't some ancient
civilization like the Mayan Empire that
had taken over a thousand years to build
at the time Montezuma's father ark sack
at all assumed the throne in 1469 the
Aztec empire had been standing less than
50 years the people we call today the
Aztecs first arrived in the valley of
Mexico in the 13th century back then the
fertile valley was basically Mesa
America's cradle of civilization great
empires like the Toltecs had risen and
fallen here but by the time the earliest
tanks arrived the days of a central
power controlling the region were over
instead the valley was a place of
innumerable city-states all fighting in
a Darwinian struggle for survival those
who were good at war flourished those
who weren't went the way of the dodo
luckily for the Aztecs war was something
that they excelled at around the Year
1325 AD at least according to tradition
the migrant Aztecs established a city on
an island in the middle of the valley
known as tennard shetland it became this
centre of power but this wasn't yet
power on a grand scale in the dark
forests of Mesoamerican society you
couldn't get too powerful without
attracting the attention of a bigger
rival it wasn't long before Tenochtitlan
found itself under the thumb of the
mighty Tampa neck Empire but in this
cutthroat era the balance of power
shifted all too easily in 1428 civil war
erupted among the tavern acts the ins
and outs are complicated but the upshot
is that 1000 chitlin allies with two
other city-states texcoco and Clark upon
to destroy the tappan a capital when the
fog of war finally cleared the to panic
Empire was no more Teno chitlins triple
alliance had one it was from this
alliance that the Aztec empire proper
would be born considering it only
appeared in 1428 the Empire expanded a
phenomenal rate if you look at a map of
Aztec conquests you'll see them go
a small smudge of territory around
modern Mexico City to a regional
superpower in the blink of an eye
by the time Montezuma was born in 1467
the Empire stretched from the Atlantic
coast to within spitting distance of the
Pacific yet it would be wrong to think
that this was an empire in the regular
sense whereas other historical empires
like the Romans integrated new conquests
into a relatively centralized state the
Aztecs were nowhere near as disciplined
conquest by the Aztecs didn't mean
becoming an Aztec citizen so much as it
meant a bunch of Nahuatl speakers
defeating you dumping a gigantic carving
of their God on your temple and then
demanding tribute hell of the words the
Aztec empire was more a bunch of loosely
aligned city-states with their own
distinct identities United mostly in
annoyance at paying all this tribute to
tarnish a plan the Empire then was vast
but it was unstable so long as it could
remain the most powerful beast in the
dark forest it would survive but the
moments are bigger stronger predator
came along well we're gonna find out
shortly what happens first though we
need to witness Montezuma's rise to
absolute power
[Music]
after Montezuma's dad axia cattle took
the throne in 1469 it must have looked
like the family was set but then axia
cattle managed to screw things up
completely in just a single decade in
1479 just after Montezuma turned ten
Axia cattle tried to conquer the
purépecha or taraskin empire only for
the parapets shirt hands the as tags but
feathered asses to them on an obsidian
platter the entire army was wiped out
given the importance the Aztecs placed
on their elites doing battle it's
probably lucky Montezuma wasn't yet old
enough to fight else this video would be
ending right about now the Montezuma was
still too young to be a warrior so he
avoided the fate of all those captured
by the Terra scans just as he avoided
the fate that his father suffered in
1480 AXI act all fell within a year he
was dead killed by a mysterious wasting
disease that today looks more like a
really unsubtle assassination via poison
exactly how the teen aged Montezuma
would have taken his dad's death is a
bit of an open question we know that as
plateau Arnie axia cattle would have
been given a send-off party befitting a
god his body burned atop a gigantic pyre
in the middle of the city
but what Montezuma would have felt upon
getting the news upon seeing his
father's mortal remains turn into smoke
and fan upwards into the night sky
we simply cannot say was he sad proud
did he swear then and there to one day
do better than his useless old man no
one knows after Axia kettles death the
Empire went through a brief lull in
which it was ruled by the magnificently
useless
tis ik before he too died of one of
those mysterious diseases in 1486 in the
wake of yet another Atlanta Lonnie
getting bumped off with poison the
council of elders finally decided to
place someone competent on the throne
and that man was Montezuma's uncle odds
or tall and he ushered in the aztec
golden age now the aztecs being the
Aztecs what was a golden age for them
was more of an age of oh please stop
conquering us through everyone else one
of the first things adds Oertel did was
celebrate his new reign by sacrificing
between 20,000 and 80,000
atop the templo mayor this gory deed
done he said about vastly expanding his
brand-new empire and guess who was by
his side the entire time by now
Montezuma had grown into a powerful
young man had been trained in the art of
Aztec warfare in diplomacy it even
served as a high priest now he just had
to prove himself in battle prove himself
worthy of his place in the royal family
luckily for Montezuma he hadn't
inherited his father's incompetence in
warfare first at our total size then as
his own man he was going to conquer more
land than any other Aztec in history and
if you would like to conquer a new skill
or improve one that you already have
well let me tell you about today's
sponsor floki floki is an app that
allows you to learn piano via a tablet
or phone it allows you to learn how to
play songs in minutes rather than weeks
or even months if you're not very good
now I used to play piano at 20 years ago
and I didn't do it well but I thought
I'd give it another go because floki
sponsored this episode so I decided to
crack out the app and have a go at it
but the best way for me to show you that
is to jump over to my home where I have
a piano everyone so welcome to my home
I come in here so this is a play key
what you do is you have your piano up
here can you see this good and then the
music down here and there's 1500 songs
you can choose from I've took chosen to
learn moonlight sonata by Beethoven so
what I prefer to use is this weight mode
and then what you do come in here come
closer and then what you do is you just
follow what the guy's hands are doing so
when you play this
and what you do is you just play along
with this guy and before you know it and
I learned this and I'm definitely gonna
screw it up as soon as I show you
[Music]
okay I've screwed up a few times but I
think that's not bad seeing as I just
follow this guy along in the app and you
learn how to play a song I think it's
pretty cool let's go back to the office
so yes floki really is an incredible app
there are over 1500 songs to choose from
from all musical genres plus 50
step-by-step courses from beginner to
advanced and I just showed you guys
weight mode with both hands but you can
also learn one hand at a time which is
perfect at the beginning or you could
just play along with the songs on slo-mo
mode or regular mode if you're feeling
bold which is a great alternative to
weight mode perfect for more challenging
sections just to slow it down a touch
anyway I fully recommend checking out
floki there is a link below and let's
get back to it
it's hard to overstate just how
important war was to the Aztecs like
their foundation myth literally involved
the God quits Allah potty leaping out of
the womb fully armed and immediately
decapitating his sister 4 Aztec males
life was effectively like being in
Street Fighter 2 it was a series of
battles in which you had to best an
endless string of opponents in order to
advance and this advancement was real
the clothes you could wear the respect
afforded to you was all tied up in the
number of people you're defeated as a
result the Aztec nobility were on the
frontlines of war not hanging back and
avoiding the slaughter not that any
slaughter happens on the battlefield
when Montezuma joined Howard's Oertel in
his campaigns of conquest he wouldn't
have been trying to kill his enemies
he'd have been fighting to disable and
to capture them why well because Aztec
warfare sprang largely from one need the
need to sacrifice humans depending on
where you get your history from you
might have either heard that the Aztecs
were monsters who sacrificed innocence
every day or alternately that all
accounts of Aztec human sacrifice were
fabricated by the Spanish tube justify
conquering them neither of these is
exactly true on the one hand it would be
nonsense to say that the Aztecs
literally sacrificed someone every
single day on the other hand sacrifice
was still something that they did a ton
of the Aztec calendar was broken up into
18 months each of which at a major
festival all of them involving human
sacrifice we know this because
excavations in 2015 and 2018 dug up huge
evidence including towers of human
skulls long thought to have been
conquistador propaganda the Aztecs
believed the gods had given their own
blood in order to create humanity this
blood dirt needed to be paid back
regularly or the world would end it was
to repay this debt that Aztec warfare
took place that young men like Montezuma
went out to take prisoners in battle and
Montezuma and uncle Howard's Oertel were
absolute experts at winning battles as
our dajjal's reign wore on the two of
them managed to finally connect to the
Empire to the Pacific coast
to overrun the oaxaca valley together
they captured zouk on a Chaco right down
on the pacific coast by the
and Guatemalan border although our total
was the mastermind Montezuma was his
trusted left hands always right in the
thick of the fighting by the time the
boy turns 30 he was renowned as a
ferocious warrior a prime candidate to
become fat Ronny
luckily the chance soon presented itself
exactly how our total died is mystery
some sources say he contracted another
of those wasting diseases while others
say that he died from a blow to the head
while escaping a flat either way the
outcome was the same in 1502 our total
the Conqueror was burned atop a massive
funeral pyre in the heart of town a
chitlin shortly after the council of
elders gathered to elect the new Aztec
leader you won't be surprised to hear
that Montezuma was the winner
one of the coolest Aztec relics is the
coronation stone of Montezuma carved as
part of the lavish ceremony surrounding
his ascension to Santa juanny it gives
us a date of year 11 read day 1
crocodile aka the 15th of July 1503 it
is one of the few specific dates we have
regarding Montezuma's life and it's a
fair bet to say that it was the greatest
day of all as clatter our new Montezuma
was given a palace to live in that would
make even the sultan of brunai vomit
with envy
there were Hanging Gardens pools of
fresh and salt water to bathe in a
private zoo filled with Jaguars and
eagles ten whole rooms dedicated to a
vast Avery 3,000 attendants fulfilled
Montezuma's every desire for just a
single meal chefs would prepare hundreds
of dishes that the Emperor could pick
from at his leisure he wore sandals made
of gold had jugglers acrobats albinos
and dwarves at his beck and call yet
Montezuma's rain wasn't just about
indulgence
there was also conquest the Eyrie was
crowned 1503 Montezuma launched a
coronation war against the city of Nepal
on but this was just the warm-up act
over the next 16 years Montezuma
initiated four major Wars eventually
growing the Empire so large it
effectively swallowed central Mexico by
the end the only viable enemies the
Aztecs had left were the pesky taraskin
su @ handed our titles asked him back in
1479 and the plaques Carla
but even the plaques Carla were hemmed
in a small enclave of hostile territory
completely surrounded by the Aztec
superpower Montezuma hadn't just fought
alongside our exotic hid learns the art
of conquest from him yet Montezuma was
even more ambitious than his uncle had
been as Clara Hwanhee Montezuma reduced
the power of his plat sail a lag I we
might call the chief of internal affairs
in effect he swiped a load of powers
elevating himself from living God to
living God who's also a dictator it's
kind of tempting to see Montezuma on the
eve of the Spanish invasion as leader in
his prime guy so powerful at the top of
his empire so great that's its collapse
at the hands of the Europeans is the
ultimate Black Swan events but that's
not exactly true
even before 1590
there were signs that Montezuma's empire
was in trouble in 1515 for example
Montezuma tried to finally tame the
plaques Carla Enclave only to suffer a
defeat almost as humiliating as the one
that told his dad in the wake of this
gigantic scrub insurrection z' broke out
in the Empire's outer provinces
city-states started looking side long at
one another quietly wondering if now
might be the time to break free of
Tenochtitlan we don't want to speculate
too much but it's possible the Empire
was already close to disintegration yes
we'll never know if it would have fallen
apart under Montezuma's rule in 1515
reports reached an archer plan of
floating temples spotted off the coast
two years later the first of these
temples landed on the shores of the
Aztec empire its grand white sails
billowing in the winds
the Aztecs didn't know it but the aliens
had just arrived travelers from another
world the old world when they finally
decided to explore Mexico it would be
the end of everything Montezuma had ever
known
almost every account you'll ever hear of
hernan cortes invasion tells it from the
point of view of the Europeans following
them as they battle their way into the
interior and they defeat city after city
certainly it makes for a juicy narrative
there's lots of adventure and 20 of
action but even more compelling might be
the narrative from inside turn out
Shipman how it must have felt as reports
of floating temples and strange white
men gave way to stories of butchery and
violence how it must have felt as those
stories got closer and closer to the
capital as the aliens drew nearer
frustratingly this is another one of
those times when we basically have to
guess so sparsa the records from the
Aztecs side but we do have some clues we
can assume Montezuma was nervous about
the invaders the moment they landed
since he sent them gifts of gold and
silver the traditional way of resolving
disputes in Aztec society unfortunately
the Europeans saw these gifts not as a
message saying thanks for coming that
you can go now but an invitation to come
and do some serious looting this brings
us to our second assumption that
Montezuma received news of the aliens
with mounting despair Cortes and his men
subdued the coastal tribes with ease
they then fought Montezuma sold enemies
the tax car Larenz once that one asked
tax Karla to join forces with him by
summer reports would have been flooding
into town our plan of the massacre at
Cholula this was where the Spaniards put
six thousand loyal Aztec subjects to the
sort you can always do Majan the fear
gripping want to see miss Hart for the
best part of a century the Aztecs had
been the top predator in the dark
forests of Mesoamerica and now here came
the super predator society one that
could brush Aztec warriors aside as
easily as Montezuma could swat a fly the
only question was how he could stop them
from destroying Tana chitlin in November
1519 the aliens were at last spotted
approaching the Aztec capital much has
been made of the fact that Montezuma put
up no resistance including the now
disproved tale that the Aztecs Latta
wani mistook Cortes for a god but there
seems to be an obvious answer Montezuma
knew that resistance was futile better
to extend the hand of
friendship and hope for the best and to
fight a battle you're destined to lose
Oh November the 8th Cortez was welcomed
inside the great city for the first time
while it was a strange experience for
the Spaniard it must have been even
stranger for Montezuma here he was
showing this unknowable warrior around
his capital pointing out its sacred
temples grand canals and flowering
gardens all while never knowing if they
would still be standing in a few days
time Montezuma could never have guessed
as he led his guests into the heart of
the temple precinct that this was the
greatest city Cortes had ever seen that
it overshadowed anything in contemporary
Europe Cortez had already decided to
present it intact to his own Emperor a
few days after the Spanish arrived
Montezuma's slowed down for began Cortez
took him hostage forcing him to swear
allegiance to Charles to the earth and
placing it under house arrest
from now on Cortez would rule the city
from behind the scenes Montezuma would
just be a figurehead a puppet for the
Spanish perhaps the last true Aztec
emperor agreed in the hopes that Cortez
would spare his people perhaps he was
simply afraid for his own life and
willing to do anything to stay alive
either way Montezuma did exactly as
Cortez wished from that moment on Aztec
society was already dead
[Music]
it's hard to think of many puppet rulers
who've had it good but perhaps few have
had it quite so bad as Montezuma
although he still lived in luxury was
still officially a deity in reality he
was nothing but a Spanish slave forced
to justify the most outrageous acts to
an increasingly angry public it was
Montezuma for example who had to go out
and calm his people when the Spaniards
placed a giant cross atop a great temple
that's if Montezuma thought that life as
caught as his lap dog was bad well it's
about to get even worse in early 1520
Cortez was called away from town Oh
Chaplin probably bore Montezuma was told
was that the Spaniard was going and
would leave pedrad alvarado in charge
this was a bad move where Cortez was
like a crafty Fox worming his way into
control of Tenochtitlan
Alvarado was like a particularly obtuse
bull that's been blindfolded and dropped
into a porcelain factory as the power
behind the curtain
Alvarado began having elite Aztecs
executed on a whim each time he made
Montezuma go out and do his thing
telling the enraged crowds that
everything was still cool as a smallpox
epidemic broke out in the empire caused
by the conquistadors 10 a chitlin
reached boiling point it was at this
time that Alvarado did something even
Montezuma couldn't justify in may 15 21
of the Aztecs great frequent rituals
took place in the temple precinct as
warriors dressed in feathers danced and
world under the dark sky drummers beat
out a rhythm rising to crescendo
preparing the city for another sacrifice
but that sacrifice never came instead
the Spaniards strode into the precinct
unsheathed their swords one by one the
greatest deck Warriors were struck down
their bodies dismembered on sacred
grounds
there was the end of Montezuma's puppet
regime tenet rippln exploded the
Spaniards were besieged the city of
200,000 Souls suddenly an inferno at
some point in June Cortes managed to
slip back in and demand won't assume go
out and calm the crowd there are two
versions of what happens next the first
is that docile to the ends Montezuma
went out onto a balcony to speak with
his people there the rioting crowd threw
rocks at their false God until
one struck him on the head and killed
him instantly the second is more prosaic
it claims the court has realized
Montezuma's usefulness was over and had
him summarily executed montezuma ii died
on either the 22nd or the 30th of June
1520 the very next night the Spanish
tried to flee tenet Japan only for
dozens of them to meet there fades
either at the hands of the Aztecs or
drowning while they tried to cross the
lake known in Spain as the night of
Tears the botched flight from 1000
Chaplin marked the point the Spanish
conquest came its closest to collapse
but it didn't quite end there just nine
months later Cortes would be back at the
head of an invasion force marching on
the Aztec capital but that's another
story for now for this video we ends
with Montezuma lying dead on a balcony
in a pool of his own blood
or perhaps bleeding out on the tip of a
Spanish sword at the end of all that
carnage then we can finally ask who
really was Montezuma ii well he was
unlucky for one if he had died of one of
those mysterious wasting diseases before
Cortez showed up it's likely he'd be
remembered as the greatest Aztec emperor
but there was more to Montezuma's life
than simply being the guy in charge when
the aliens arrived although much of it
is mysterious Montezuma story remains a
window into an entire other world into a
culture so different from ours that we
can never hope to fully understand it
yet in this tale of his struggles in his
life and death we can still catch enough
glimpses of the Aztec world to wonder
what it must have been like how it must
have felt to be living in this time and
this place when the apocalypse finally
arrived the Spanish may have wiped out
Montezuma Zampa
they may have ground his people into
dust but his name still lives on a
reminder of an entirely forgotten world
so I really hope you enjoyed that video
if you did please do hit that thumbs up
button below do not forget to subscribe
also please do check and our fantastic
sponsor floki who i'm linked
you below and thank you for watching
[Music]